Here's an outline of my answer and
again I'll build it up piece by piece.
The first part is similar to what
we did for duplicating a string.
We first write a blank
to the second tape.
Then we copy the first part
of our input string to it.
The x part.
And then we rewind the second tape.
We can illustrate this idea like this.
We started by copying x
from Tape 1 to Tape 2.
And positioned the head on
Tape 1 at the start of y,
that is the text we want to search in.
And then we rewound the head on Tape 2,
so that it's positioned at the beginning
of the key string, the thing we're
going to look for within the text y.
At this point we move to state q3.
In here we walk forward on both
tapes as long as we have a match.
If we reach the blank
cell at the end of x,
then we've found a matching
substring and we accept.
If we reach a blank on the first tape,
then we reject,
since that means that x is longer than
the remaining portion of y, the search.
And if we find a mismatch
between these two at any point,
then we rewind one step on Tape 2,
and then we rewind both tapes until
we get back to the beginning of x.
And then we can repeat
this time will be checking
x against a substring of y
that's one further space down.